it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grandchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
sagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns